Es kann auch sein, dass DNA nichts mehr ist als ein Programm, das sich selbst zu bewahren hat. Aber er definiert Menschheit. Die Erinnerung von Computern und die stetige Erkundung unkaltierter Daten hat einen neuen Erinnerungssystem und Erinnerung parallel zu deinem eigenen. Die Menschheit hat die Konsequenzen der Computerisierung unterstellt.
Nullsinn!
Wie kannst du, wenn weder die modernen Wissenschaften, noch die Philosophie, was Leben ist, erklären können?
Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express Ausgabe Nummer 79. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch zum wiederholten Male. Hier bei Chaos Radio Express, wo es um Dinge geht, wo ihr euch immer gegengewehrt habt, dass ihr euch mal jemand erzählt. Aber ihr habt keine Chance, denn ihr habt zugeschaltet bei unserem Podcast. Und heute ist der 14. März 2008. Ich weile in Berlin. Ich bin also sozusagen nicht auf einer großen Reise, aber ich habe mich aus dem Haus getraut, um einer Veranstaltung beizuwohnen, die jetzt hier gerade ganz klandestin mitten in Berlin, mitten im BVG-Streik abgehalten wird. Unter dem Titel GTK plus Hackfest haben sich hier eine größere Teilmenge Programmierer zusammengefunden, aus aller Welt, wie es den Anschein hat. Das können wir gleich noch mal aufzählen, wo sie alle herkommen. Ich habe mir mal zwei kompetente Ansprechpartner hier herausgepickt, um der Sache ein wenig auf den Grund zu gehen. Ich begrüße zu meiner Linken Tim Janik und Sven Herzberg. Ihr beide seid ja Teil der GTK plus Community, oder sagt man Gnome-Community. Ich weiß es nicht so ganz genau.
Es gibt eigentlich beide Communities.
Es gibt beide und die trudeln so nebeneinander her.
Ja, und wir sind eigentlich Member von beiden Communities.
Okay, das war auch mal mein Eindruck. Und das soll auch unser Thema und Titel heute sein, Gnome und GTK. Das andere GUI, der andere Desktop unter Linux, der sich größerer Popularität erfreut, neben KDE, das sind, glaube ich, mit Abstand die populärsten Subsysteme. Gibt es eigentlich noch weitere? Ich weiß gar nicht.
Es gibt noch ein paar kleinere Projekte, Xfce, RoX, dann gibt es natürlich noch Enlightenment.
Aber das sind halt nicht so große Ansätze, die jetzt wirklich versuchen, die Sache von unten bis oben komplett zu lösen.
Also sowohl von der Applikation als auch von der Installationsbasis her sind wirklich die beiden großen Projekte KDE und Gnome, das ist vollkommen richtig.
Genau, es regiert sozusagen das G und das K. Ob nun das K oder das G mehr regiert, das ist sicherlich Ansichtssache. Beide Systeme scheinen so ihre ganz spezifischen Anhänger gefunden zu haben. Das war schon immer so mein Eindruck. Das Gnome Projekt, ich hatte hier vor einiger Zeit schon mit Sven Neumann gesprochen zum GIMM Projekt, was ja ein bisschen die Ua-End-User-Applikation ist.
Das ist so eine Art Ursuppe für GTK.
Genau, das hat man auch besprochen. Das war dann eben auch so die Ursuppe, weil GTK, wir können es ja mal auflösen, steht nach wie vor für GIMP Toolkit.
Richtig.
Dann ist da immer noch dieses Plus hinten dran. Was hat es eigentlich damit auf sich?
Da muss man wirklich ein bisschen zurückgehen, gucken, wie GTK genau entstanden ist. Ursprünglich ist ja GIMP an der Berkeley-Universität entwickelt worden. Ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ob das jetzt ein reines Hobbyprojekt war, aber ich glaube, früh oder später haben die tatsächlich angefangen, innerhalb von Kursen einige von den Bildverarbeitungsalgorithmen zu entwickeln und dann GIMP zu integrieren, an denen die da an der Uni halt auch rum gelernt und rumgeprobt haben. Und es ist natürlich klar, dass für ein Bildverarbeitungsprogramm wie GIMP ein grafisches Toolkit vonnöten ist.
Also unter Toolkit verstehst du sozusagen einen Satz von Routinen, mit dem man nicht immer wieder alles komplett neu machen muss.
Richtig, also die Library oder Bibliothek, die Funktionalität implementiert, wie Buttons, also Knöpfe, Anacui darzustellen, Scrollbars, Textfelder, das Anzeigen von Bildern, diese Notebook-Taps, die man umblättern kann, das Menüsystem. All diese Dinge möchte man ja nicht für jedes Programm neu programmieren. Und deshalb gibt es halt diese Standardbibliotheken in dem Bereich. Und 95, das war so die Zeit, wo GIMP da ursprünglich am entstehen war, ich glaube 94, 95 die Jahre, da war halt das, was unter UNIX zur Verfügung stand, MOTIV. Das war ein proprietäres Toolkit damals. Und deshalb haben tatsächlich die Ursprungsversionen von GIMP auf Motor auch gesetzt. Wobei GIMP dann selber freies Software war. Und das war eigentlich insofern eine unglückliche Lösung, dass nicht der gesamte Softwarestack da frei war und MOTIV auch nicht immer sämtlichen Anforderungen gerecht worden ist, die GIMP eigentlich ans grafische Toolkit gestellt hat. Und dann haben halt die, die Ursprungsprogrammiere von GIMP, das waren hier Spencer Kimball, Peter Mathis und Josh McDonald. Die haben sich halt überlegt, ob sie nicht unter Umständen ein eigenes Toolkit schreiben, insbesondere Peter Mathis hatte eigentlich immer schon so ein bisschen die Idee gehabt, ein eigenes Toolkit wäre wahrscheinlich ganz interessant zu implementieren. Und der hat tatsächlich irgendwann damit angefangen, das war so eigentlich Anfang 96, einige Strukturen, sagen wir mal, unter C zusammenzustellen, die dann in einem Button entsprechend ein paar Rendering-Routine auf der Exib aufzusetzen und hat dann ungefähr so in einem halben Jahr eigentlich die Grundpfosten von GTK aus dem Boden gestampft. Das waren eigentlich so die Basis-Vidgets, sodass man, ich glaube es gibt von 96 Sommer eine Gimp-Release, wo tatsächlich ein GTK drin ist, weil da einfach nur ein Haufen C-Strukturen und ein paar Funktionen sind, die eben schon so anfänglich ein paar User-Interfaces, Elemente zur Verfügung stellen. Und danach hat er eigentlich ein bisschen, also das war noch sehr, sehr stark im Rahmen des Gimp-Projektes, da ist selbst was drin. Wir reden auch hier tatsächlich von Kot, der im Gimp-Tarboll gewesen ist damals. Und dann hat er eigentlich in den darauffolgenden Monaten so ein bisschen den GTK-Kram ausgegliedert, ein bisschen generischer gemacht, sodass dann Ende 1996 es eigentlich die ersten GTK-Tarbolls gab und der Kot auch umgemodelt wurde, um mehr in Richtung von Objektorientierung zu gehen. Und mehr in Richtung von Objektorientierung heißt, dass man tatsächlich Verschachtelung von C-Strukturen genommen hat, um Vererbung in C nachzuimplementieren. Ich sage mal nachimplementieren hier, weil damals gab es ja schon C++. Und da hat man eigentlich auch das Verschachtelung von Strukturen, was als Vererbung benutzt wird, nur ist das vollkommen vom Compiler versteckt. Und in der C-Implementation von GTK muss natürlich direkt gemacht werden vom Programmierer selber. Da kann man tatsächlich sehen, im Prinzip kann man sich da angucken, so von einer Pike auf, wie wird eigentlich Objektorientierung implementiert.
95, 96, das ist jetzt der Zeitraum, von dem ich spreche.
Das ist jetzt eigentlich das zweite Halbjahr 96.
Das war ja, sag ich mal, so objektorientierte Programmierung. Das war zwar etwas, was sich Firmen gerne auf ihre Messestände geschrieben haben, aber dass das so in allgemeiner Benutzung gewesen wäre, davon kann, glaube ich, nicht unbedingt die Rede sein. Es gibt da noch mal so ein paar Inseln, wo das sehr verbreitet war. Ich denke, es ging da schon richtig groß da. Ja, das war die Geburtsstunde. Aber alles, was sozusagen da war, was benutzt wurde, sagen wir mal zum Beispiel auf dem Macintosh, was ja so die GUI war oder so, da gab es das halt nicht. Da war das irgendwie alles prozedural, da wurde teilweise noch am Anfang mit Turbo Pascal und später dann auch mit C gemacht. Aber es gab diesen objektorientierten Ansatz, der ja heute den Mac durchdringt, den gab es dann halt nicht. Und war eben von daher auch sonst nirgendwo vertreten, auch bei Windows nicht. Also Objektorientierung aufzugreifen an der Stelle war ja dann schon mal auch eine relativ wichtige und schwerwiegende Entscheidung. Jetzt sagst du, es gab C++, aber C++ wurde ja so nicht verwendet. Also es war ja nicht ein, man musste ja nicht C++ programmieren, um GTK zu benutzen.
Nein, das musste man damals nicht. Das ist richtig, aber trotzdem war es eigentlich schon relativ weit etabliertes, neues Programmierparadigma. Also es gab da schon wirklich viele Bücher an den C++-Compilern, die schon seit mehreren Jahren gearbeitet wurden. Es gab damals eben auch schon GTK, also G++ eigentlich, der tatsächlich C++ im Features für freie Software zur Verfügung gestellt hat. Allerdings war die Unterstützung nicht annähernd da, wo sie heute ist. Das muss man wirklich sagen. Ich habe persönlich auch 96 nach einem Toolkit gesucht, allerdings für ein Musikprogramm. Ich habe mich nach einem freien Toolkit umgeschaut und das Einzige, was ich damals entdeckt hatte, war Less Tiff. Less Tiff ist eine Nachprogrammierung von Motif, allerdings auch in C, praktisch eine Art freier Ersatz für Motif. Ich wollte eigentlich ein C++-Toolkit haben. Damals habe ich mich hingesetzt und versucht, einen C++-Rapper für Less Tiff zu schreiben. Ich kann einfach nur sagen, das hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Wenn ich keine Probleme mit C++ bzw. mit G++ hatte, also der Implementation von GCC damals von C++, dann hatte ich Probleme mit der mangelnden Toolkit-Unterstützung, die in Less Tiff damals gerade wirklich so in den Kinderschuhen war. Deshalb habe ich mich persönlich eigentlich nach einem Toolkit umgeguckt und bin auf GTK gestoßen durch einen AIX-Artikel damals, der eigentlich über Gimp ging und habe mich Ende 1996 an Peter Mattes gewandt, um mir die neuesten GTK-Versionen zu holen, die er da hatte. Und da war eigentlich gerade dabei, das Plus in GTK zu implementieren.
Und was ist das Plus?
Was ist das Plus? Also die eigentliche Vererbung, die GTK unterstützt, ist eine relativ normale Single-Inheritance-Vererbung, wo also ein Objekt genau einen Parent hat und die Funktionalität erweitert. Und in C++ ist es eigentlich gang und gäbe, das sieht man gut, wenn man sich ein QT-Programm oder so anguckt, eine Widget-Klasse zu verwenden, davon abzuleiten, also im Applikationscode zu vererben und die Funktionalität zu erweitern bzw. neue Datenmember und so weiter daran zu hängen. Und ich muss sagen, dass die Vererbungsmechanismen, die die GTK zur Verfügung gestellt hat, die waren relativ oder verhältnismäßig aufwendig zu benutzen, weil das eben alles in C gemacht wurde. Also es ist wirklich so, wenn man Objektorientierung selber in C programmiert, hat man den Vorteil, dass man alles selber implementieren kann und man hat den Nachteil, dass man alles selber implementieren muss. Das ist natürlich dementsprechend aufwendig gewesen. Viel Beutercode musste geschrieben werden für Vererbung. Deshalb gab es da diese Idee, einen Englisch-Sachtmann-Customization, also so eine Art Anpassungsmechanismus zu erlauben, der sehr flexibel ist, der einem erlaubt, das Verhalten von Widgets zu verändern, ohne jetzt aber gleich die Notwendigkeit, von der Klasse tatsächlich komplett ableiten zu müssen. Und das ist eigentlich diese Signal-Idee. Die nimmt das Konzept der Callback-Liste, wo man tatsächlich eine Reihe von Funktionen aufruft. Das ist eigentlich so dieses Observer-Pattern. Ich möchte was von dir wissen. Ich sag dir mal Bescheid, dass du mir Bescheid gibst. Und je nachdem, wenn bei dir was passiert, dann wirst du mich aufrufen. Diese Callback-Geschichte, die wurde zusammen mit den virtuellen Methoden verknüpft zu einem Signalsystem.
Um noch mal zusammenzufangen, dieser objektorientierte Ansatz in GTK ist eher geleitet von den abstrakten Ideen der objektorientierten Programmierung, orientiert sich aber nicht so sehr jetzt an den konkreten Ausprägungen der Objektorientierung in einer bestimmten Programmiersprache.
Das kann man wirklich so sagen.
Das finde ich auch so eine Besonderheit, weil wir hatten ja schon Couté erwähnt, also das Subsystem, was beim KDE-Desktop zum Einsatz kommt, was ja hier auch bei Chaos Radio Express vor kurzem beschrieben wurde, weil die ja gerade auf Version 4 gewechselt sind, da gab es ein interessantes Gespräch zu. Couté setzt vollständig auf C++ und sagt, okay, wir haben hier Objektorientierung und zwar haben wir die Objektorientierung von C++. Und wenn du eine andere Programmiersprache verwendest, dann musst du halt selber zusehen, wie du das irgendwie ran gedockt bekommst. Sag ich jetzt mal so, ganz einfach so, nicht? Und bei GTK ist es halt ganz anders, da sagt man, okay, wir gehen von dem grundlegendsten aus, was es gibt, nämlich C, also universellere Poemiersprachen- ansatz, denke ich, gibt es nicht. So bei den Hochsprachen, das ist ja sozusagen das Assembler der Hochsprachen und hat keine Objektorientierung, das heißt, die Objektorientierung ist eine Funktionalität von GTK und jetzt geht man also her und schaut sich an, okay, was gibt es in der Objektorientierung, was brauchen wir denn so? Klar, wir brauchen irgendwie Vererbung und Vererbung geht es irgendwie gar nicht. Was kommt dann noch dazu?
Die virtuellen Methoden eigentlich, dass ich also eine Klasse habe, auf der ich eine Funktion aufrufe und wenn...
Also beziehungsweise überhaupt erst mal Klassen, so, ganz klar, ne?
Ja, man kann auch ruhig erst mal Strukturen sein. Ich habe eine Struktur, zu der eine Funktion gehört, dass dann dieses Klassen- Methoden-Konzept und ich kann diese Klassen erweitern und damit meine Funktionen sowohl auf der Ursprungsstruktur, beziehungsweise Klasse, als auch auf der abgeleiteten funktionieren, da brauchen wir eigentlich schon diese virtuellen Methoden, die tatsächlich über eine Funktionstabelle gehen, die bei GTK auch tatsächlich in einer Klassenstruktur vorliegt, die man in Headerfiles sehen kann und bei C++ zum Beispiel implizit vom Compiler versteckt wird. Aber die Funktionalität ist die gleiche. Wir haben diese virtuelle Methode, wo wir über eine Funktionstabelle gehen, die für verschiedene Objekte unterschiedlich implementiert werden kann. Dadurch kriegen wir dieses unterschiedliche Verhalten für verschiedene Klassen implementiert. Bei GTK ist das auch noch an die Signale geknüpft. Da kann man bei vielen, vielen virtuellen Methoden ein Callback mit dranhängen, damit der aufgerufen wird, also vom User tatsächlich in der Applikation, wenn eine virtuelle Methode ausgeführt wird. Dass dieser Signalmechanismus wie GTK implementiert und die große Flexibilität, die der mitbringt, die hat eigentlich dann, aufgrund der hat Peter Mathes damals entschlossen, GTK in GTK Plus umzubenennen und hat eigentlich dann die ersten GTK Plus Tarbolts Anfang 1997 ins Netz gestellt.
Das heißt, damit wurde nicht nur ein GUI Toolkit aufgerufen, sondern es wurde sozusagen auch eine eigene Objektorientierungsabstraktion in die Welt gesetzt.
Man kann tatsächlich ein bisschen sagen eigen, ja, weil wie gesagt dieser Signalmechanismus eigentlich relativ spezifisch da und ich hatte ja eben schon in den Kontext gesetzt, dass wir nicht so einfach ableiten können und deshalb hat er sehr viel Sinn gemacht, um das Verhalten von Widgets zu beeinflussen, ohne zu vererben. Und muss auch sagen, dass einige andere objektorientierte Paradigmen oder Vorschläge, die das Programmiermodell bringt, nicht so rigoros angewendet worden sind, zum Beispiel das Verstecken von Strukturelementen oder Klassen, dieses Ceiling-Konzept, das was man bei C++ als private oder protected hat, das wurde am Anfang überhaupt nicht verfolgt und das sind auch Dinge, die tatsächlich immer noch die Code-Basis praktisch uns mitbringt vererbungstechnisch hier.
Also GTK hat sozusagen seine eigene Objektorientierungslaufzeitumgebung, kann man sagen, die halt spezifisch auf den Bedarf dieses GUI-Systems hin entwickelt ist.
Hat es geschaffen, hat es aber auch schaffen müssen, weil es eben C war und trotzdem objektorientiert.
Das hast du ja schon gesagt, man hat den Vorteil, man kann alles selber schreiben. Es hat den Nachteil, man muss alles selber schreiben. Leute, die jetzt, sagen wir mal, viel Erfahrung in objektorientierten Programmiersprachen wie C++ haben, die sind natürlich schnell dabei und sagen, warum denn noch jetzt noch mal eine komplette neue Welt erfinden, wenn ich das in meiner Programmiersprache schon drin habe? Also, warum? Ich gehe jetzt mal davon aus, dass du irgendwie dieser Methodik was abgewinnen kannst. Was ist da der Vorteil für die Programmierung?
Technisch, wie gesagt, man muss eigentlich wieder in den Zeitrahmen, das war Mitte der 90er, da wurden natürlich das komplette Gimp-File in C geschrieben. Das war damals wirklich das Gimp Toolkit, weil er am Anfang auch in Gimp geschippt und von daher auch wurde es in der Sprache implementiert, in der Gimp geschrieben ist, nämlich in C. Und muss auch sagen, was es tatsächlich damals noch gab, als Zuge ist, XT, das gibt es zwar heute noch, aber es ist eigentlich total ein Vergessnergerät und fast niemand benutzt das. Und XT ist halt auch objektorientiert, aber auch in einer Weise implementiert, dass es wirklich nicht einfach zu benutzen ist. Und das war eigentlich so das andere Vorbild, auf das man eigentlich gucken konnte, wenn man damals GTK unter X implementiert hat. Also muss man auch dazu sagen, dass das immer sehr x-zentrisch war, also an das X11-Windowsystem angelehnt. Und hat halt viele Konzepte, die X11 bringt, auch an den Programmierer durchgereicht, teilweise vereinfacht, aber auf jeden Fall in der Event-Struktur, so wie das Malen, also Drawing und sowas, verarbeitet wurde und auch die Windows in den Widgets und das alles sehr, sehr x-zentrisch noch. Also gerade da gewesen und das wurde erst später in der Entwicklung bei GTK, wo dann tatsächlich das Interesse aufkam, zum Beispiel Gimp komplett nach Windows zu porten, da wurde das dann eigentlich so als Problem entdeckt. Davor war es eigentlich tatsächlich ein Vorteil, weil man dadurch weniger selber implementieren musste. Und dann später, als die Plattform-Abstraktionen kamen, da hat man halt gemerkt, dass doch viele Dinge im Toolkit durchgereicht wurden, die nicht unbedingt für ein Toolkit notwendig sind, die halt durchgereicht worden sind, weil es X-Konzepte sind und die durchgeschieden haben.
Das heißt, diese Abhängigkeit von X-Windows, die ist gesunken über die Zeit?
Die ist zwar gesunken, aber also das ist eine von den Sachen, wo es auch immer noch Sinn macht, die zu reduzieren, wo man kann.
Da können wir vielleicht auch nochmal gleich drüber kommen, weil das ist ja auch einer der Gründe, warum ihr euch hier überhaupt getroffen habt. Vielleicht nochmal kurz zu dieser Programmiersprache-Geschichte, weil ich das ganz interessant finde. Dieser Mechanismus heißt ja G-Object, oder?
Das ist übrigens erst 2000, 2001 gewesen. Ursprünglich sprechen wir gerade von GTK-Object. Es gab damals auch G-Lib, das war eigentlich eine Library, die so ein paar C-Utility-Funktionen gesammelt hat. Später wurde das dann ausgeliefert, hat ja gerade angerissen hier. Dann wurde eigentlich GTK zusammen mit G-Lib aus Gimp ausgegliedert, kam in extra Tabol. Dann hat sich eine Community drum gebildet, die auch da einen tessigen Versionsverwaltungssystem dafür aufgesetzt hat, CVS. Das ist so in ungefähr ein halbes Jahr, bevor Gnome entstanden ist. Als dann Gnome entstand, das war dann nämlich nur 97 die Zeit, da kam dann auch die Idee auf, dass vielleicht sinnvoll ist, G-Lib auszugliedern. Dann kam das in so einen eigenen Tabol, kam in sein eigenes Versionsverwaltungsmodul unter CVS. Und als wir dann am Anfang Schritt für Schritt die 1.0er eigentlich fertig gemacht von GTK, danach die 1.2er, wo wir eigentlich mit vielen Sachen aufgeräumt haben, die in 1.0 noch nicht so ganz gepasst hatten, und dann war so die Frage, wo gehen wir jetzt hin? Und dann haben wir halt relativ tief in die Tricks gegriffen und so viele große Änderungen rausgezogen und gesagt, die möchte man eigentlich noch in dem Toolkit haben, auch wenn es hier einiges an Migrationsaufwand bedarf, um das hinzubekommen. Und das ist eigentlich so die lange Zeit gewesen, wo wir die 1.2.0.0 implementiert haben. Und da ist eben unter anderem auch von der Community der Wunsch aufgekommen, dass man das GTK-Objekt ausgliedert, dass das Objektsystem als solches nicht mehr GUI-Vigit spezifisch zur Verfügung gestellt wird, sondern komplett als, sagen wir mal, C-Utility. Und damit ging es eigentlich in GLEB rein. Und das ging, ich hatte parallel dazu, wie ich eben schon erwähnt hatte, ich habe ursprünglich an einem Musikprogramm gearbeitet, ich hatte eigentlich mein eigenes zweites Objektsystem aufgezogen in B-Side als BSE-Objektsystem, wo ich so die GTK-Konzepte noch mal reimplementierte, also ein bisschen generischer. Und als dann dieser Wunder aufkam, auf GLEB-Ebene ein Objektsystem zur Verfügung zu stellen, da habe ich eigentlich dieses BSE-Objektsystem noch mal aufgeräumt und als G-Objekt in GLEB reingepackt. Und das ist ja tatsächlich schon 2000, 2001 so gewesen, also kurz vor der 2.0er. Und dann kamen in die 2.0er halt noch viele andere Änderungen an dem Toolkit rein, die wirklich interessant waren, u.a. eben auch neue Fontverarbeitungen, also solche Dinge.
Okay, lass uns nicht so weit abschauen. Also am Ende ist aber ein G-Object entstanden. Das heißt, dieser eigentliche Objektmechanismus ist vollständig unabhängig eigentlich von GTK, mit dieser 2.0-Version, okay. Und ist sozusagen eigentlich ein Auslagern dieser Objektabstraktion in einer eigenen Library, die eigentlich auch unabhängig ist von GTK mittlerweile.
Ja, und sogar noch ein bisschen mehr. Also in der Migration von GTK zu G-Object, da haben wir natürlich das Signalsystem neu geschrieben, auch die Vererbung, ein neues Typ-System. Und wir haben auch Properties eingeführt, die es eigentlich so vorher nicht gab. Das sind tatsächlich Felder, die man auf die Objekte setzen kann, die man zur Laufzeit abfragen kann mit Introspektionsmechanismen. Die stellen dann solche Dinge zur Verfügung wie Minimum, Maximum-Werte für Properties, aber auch so etwas wie Two-Tips, die man an einer GUI anzeigen kann. Das war sehr interessant, um da GUI-Bilder generisch drauf aufsetzen zu können.
Zunächst einmal, darauf wollte ich jetzt kurz hinaus, es ist jetzt sozusagen so weit entkoppelt, sowohl jetzt von der GUI, also von dem GTK als solchen, als auch von der Programmiersprache C. Es ist in C geschrieben, aber es ist ja nicht Bestandteil der Sprache, sondern es ist ja eine eigene Laufzeit. Das heißt, man kann es auch aus anderen Programmiersprachen heraus verwenden.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich noch ein spezieller Fokus gewesen für G-Object in 2.0, weil wir eigentlich nach GTK 1.0 so viele andere Sprachen gehabt haben, also Skript-Sprachen, Perl, Python und so, die Interesse daran hatten, Toolkit-ARPIs anzubieten. Und die haben eigentlich sich hauptsächlich auf GTK gestürzt, um das anzubieten und zu rappen, weil es bei QT das Problem gab, dass einmal die Sprache als Abhängigkeit da war, mal abgesehen von der Lizenz, die auch Gnome im Endeffekt gestartet hat. Und auch, dass die Konzepte, die in QT angeboten wurden, praktisch dem Benutzer sehr oder stark C++ zentrisch waren. Die ließen sich nicht immer gut in der Skript-Sprache umsetzen. Und die einfachen Objektorientierungsmechanismen in G-Objekt, diese Einfachvererbung und mit G-Objekt selber dann auch das Supporten von Interfaces, sowie der Signalmechanismus, die ließen sich gut in andere Sprachen mappen. Und bei G-Object speziell haben wir tatsächlich auch Wert darauf gelegt, dass die anderen Weise, wie diese Mechanismen implementiert sind, generisch genug sind und die Callback- und User-Data-Möglichkeiten bieten, die Skript-Sprachen brauchen. Tatsächlich wirklich in den Fokus darauf gelegt, das komplett bindable zu machen, wie das englische Wort, ich weiß gar nicht genau, wie man es auf Deutsch sagt.
Bindbar, ja. Also, dass man halt andocken kann. So würde ich es mal ausdrücken. Dass man mit einer anderen Vorhörmessprache auf gleicher Augenhöhe arbeiten kann, aber dabei sozusagen den kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner von Objektorientierung quasi gefunden hat.
Ja, das ist ein klarer Fokus gewesen, richtig.
Das heißt, ich kann heute auch Anwendungen in GTK entwickeln, die jetzt nicht in C geschrieben sind. Und das geht vielleicht sogar ein bisschen einfacher. Ist gleichwertig, ja. Das heißt, ich habe dieselbe Mächtigkeit.
Man hat im Allgemeinen höchstens das Problem, dass das Language-Binding, sagen wir mal ein halbes Jahr oder ein Jahr nach der eigentlichen GTK-Version wirklich in vollem Feature-Set unterstützt, weil die Leute natürlich auch daran arbeiten müssen. Aber der Funktionsumfang wäre eigentlich komplett durchgereicht.
Okay, das heißt, das ist eigentlich etwas, wo sich jetzt das GTK-Projekt dann auch ganz signifikant von zum Beispiel Qt unterscheidet.
Soweit ich weiß, ist das bei Qt kein solch starker Fokus gewesen.
Ja, vielleicht um das nochmal abzuschließen, das ist ja auch alles so diese Zeit gewesen, so Ende der 90er Jahre, wo so Objekt-Interaktion auch so ein ganz heißes Thema war, so ein Software-Engineering, Stichwort so CORBA, also solche Subsysteme, wo dann eben ja solche Gesamtsysteme aus Programmen, die in unterschiedlichen Programmiersprachen geschrieben sind, entstehen sollten. Ich halte das für weitgehend gescheitert. Eigentlich hat man sich dann irgendwann mal freudestrahlend dann auf Java gestürzt, weil man dann diesen ganzen Klimmbimm nicht mehr hat. Dann hat man gesagt, okay, wir verzichten dann jetzt mal auf ein paar Features. Aber Hauptsache, wir haben da so einen gemeinsamen Nenner und kriegen den Code schnell auf die Maschinen geworfen. Das ist sicherlich so ein Teil, der zu Java beigetragen hat, aber ich will jetzt nicht so sehr über Java reden. Aber da ist ja sozusagen auch dieses Geoject nochmal ein eigener Ansatz, der ja auch bis heute überlebt hat.
Im Prinzip will ich diese Einfachvererbung, die von so gut wie jeder Hochsprache, die OO in irgendeiner Form unterstützt, angeboten wird. Und im Allgemeinen kann man das eigentlich auch von den Interfaces sagen.
Wer verwendet denn GTK? Also wer benutzt es? Außer...
Gimp?
Also, ja, ich meine jetzt nicht so... das ist klar. Das ist wahrscheinlich dann auch die letzte Anwendung, die es unterstützt. Da sollte es irgendwann mal von diesem Planeten verschwinden. Aber das ist nicht das, was ich meine. Also für wen ist GTK ein geeignetes System? Für wen eignet sich das? Also die Frage, welchen Anwendungsbereich...
Die klingt insofern ein bisschen komisch, dass es eigentlich kaum einen Anwendungsbereich gibt, von dem wir sagen, da sollte GTK nicht eingesetzt werden.
Also das ist tatsächlich... Ich würde jetzt nicht mit GTK implementieren.
Nein, natürlich eine grafische Anwendung.
Wir reden schon natürlich...
Die grafische Oberflächen haben, aber...
Ja, auch im Sinne von Plattform. Natürlich ist Linux, denke ich mal, das primäre Target, aber GTK läuft ja auch nicht nur unter Linux-Systemen, oder?
Nein, ich glaube, relativ früh halt das Bedürfnis, Ende der 90er schon, dass Gimp auf Windows läuft. Deshalb gab es eben diesen Gimp-Windows-Port und in dem Rahmen wurden Teile, oder wurden eigentlich die wesentlichen Teile von Gleb und dann später auch von GTK selber, nach Windows geportet. Und Gimp läuft ja eigentlich auch, es ist voll funktionsfähig unter Windows dieser Tage. Und es gab dann auch weitere Backends für GTK selber, zum Beispiel auch Direct-FB, dass es tatsächlich unter Linux eingesetzt werden konnte, ohne X11. Und jetzt gibt es auch noch den Mac OS X-Port. Also im Prinzip werden eigentlich alle großen Plattformen inzwischen unterstützt, kann man sagen.
Gibt es den schon, den Mac OS X-Port? Ich habe nur davon gehört, dass es den geben soll irgendwann mal.
Ja, den gibt es. Der ist vor zwei Jahren wirklich im Rahmen einer Studienarbeit gestartet worden und ist jetzt zurzeit in einem Status, wo dann zum Beispiel Anwendungen wie der Gimp, wenn man den dann entsprechend unter OS X fährt, dann auch die entsprechende globale Menüleiste mit benutzen, wie jede andere Mac OS X Anwendung das auch macht. Wer ist das? Wir arbeiten noch an Native Theming, also dass die Anwendung dann unter OS X aussieht, wie eine OS X Anwendung und vor allem halt auch unter Tiger dann aussieht, wie die anderen Anwendungen unter Tiger und unter Leopard dann unter Leopard, weil da ja auch wieder einige Änderungen im Theming vom System selber stattgefunden haben. Das ist noch Work-in-Progress, aber benutzbar ist.
Ja, aber was ist denn da der Ansatz? Das ist ja immer so ein großes Problem mit Cross-Plattformen. Früher musste man sich nur darum kümmern, dass es überhaupt erst mal kompiliert und dass es irgendwas ist, aber es gab in der Regel nicht so viele Dinge, die man so berücksichtigen muss. Jetzt gerade bei Mac OS X, da tritt man natürlich so ein bisschen in die Höhle des Löwen ein, weil Mac OS X natürlich jetzt nicht mehr irgendwie hübsche Buttons hat, sondern dahinter sich ja auch eine reiche Funktionalität verbirgt. So was weiß ich. So was Einfaches wie, wie kann ich editieren in einem Textfeld, was ja mehr ist als nur eintippen und irgendwie die Backspace-Taste drücken, sondern da kann ich irgendwie was markieren und Reck und Drop machen, und dann kann ich irgendwie was reinziehen, und dann kann ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, komische Tasten machen. Das ist jetzt immer so die Frage, wenn ich mit so einem Cross-Platform GUI-System ankomme und ich sage, ok, alles klar, GTK, da kann ich sowohl für Linux entwickeln, als auch vielleicht für irgendeine kleine Embedded-Plattform. Und wenn ich es brauche, läuft es dann halt auch auf dem Mac. Das ist natürlich die Frage, wie sieht es dann wirklich aus im Vergleich, also in der Funktionalität, im Vergleich zu anderen Anwendungen?
Auf der jeweiligen Zutatform?
Auf der jeweiligen Plattform. Also wie weit tritt dann das GTK sozusagen auch selber zurück, nach dem Motto, ah, hier gibt es etwas, worum ich mich jetzt auf der Plattform kümmern muss, aber auf dieser Plattform gibt es das ja schon. Da lasse ich das dann einfach das Betriebssystem machen.
Da muss man natürlich grundsätzlich sagen, dass es verschiedene Ansätze gibt, Cross-Plattform zu entwickeln. Das eine ist nämlich, welche Applikation zu haben, die tatsächlich auf jeder Plattform die nativen Widgets benutzt, was im Allgemeinen ein wesentlich mehr Aufwand ist. Und dann gibt es eben den Ansatz, sagen wir mal, auf ein Toolkit zu setzen und das Toolkit dann backend-technisch auf die verschiedenen Plattformen zu porten. Ich glaube tatsächlich sogar, dass der Open-Office-Ansatz auch so funktioniert. Bei GTK ist es so, dass es eigentlich erst mal darum gegangen ist, die Code-Basis auf verschiedene Systeme unten übersetzen zu können. Da war eigentlich ganz am Anfang mal so der Port von 32 auf 64 Bit. Das wurde noch unter Linux gemacht. Und dann natürlich andere Graphicship-Agents zu unterstützen, wie ich hier schon erwähnt habe, hier Direct-FB und dann eben Windows. Aber wenn tatsächlich unter Windows auch GTK-Vidgets angezeigt und nicht die Windows-Vidgets verwendet. Und auf der Basis bewegt sich eigentlich auch der Mac OS X-Port hier oder zwischendurch. Es gab auch mal ein BOS-Port. Als es BOS gab, gab es ein BOS-Port. Jetzt wo es kein BOS mehr gibt, gibt es auch kein BOS-Port mehr, kann man glaube ich so sagen. Im Allgemeinen ist es aber hier wirklich immer so gewesen, dass die GTK-Vidgets einfach nur woanders angezeigt werden konnten und sich nicht durch die nativen Widgets ausgetauscht haben. Von daher ist GTK ein Toolkit, das auf mehreren Plattformen läuft, aber keine Cross-Plattform-Toolkit-Anbindung für Applikationen.
Okay, das heißt, wenn man auf, was weiß ich, man hat eine Software und die muss jetzt vor allem unter Windows benutzt werden oder unter Gnome vielleicht sogar so. Aber man sagt, aus bestimmten Gründen wäre es für uns extrem wichtig, dass es zumindest auch auf Mac oder unter Windows eben auch läuft. Es muss jetzt nicht unbedingt sich da wunderbar einbinden und tra la la und alle Features nutzen, sondern wenn es zumindest dieselbe Funktionalität bereitstellt, wie auch auf dem anderen System und da eben auch läuft, dass man es da eben benutzen kann, dann sind wir schon glücklich. Das wäre sozusagen etwas, wo man dann eben glücklich zu GTK greifen könnte.
Das ist eigentlich genau das Ziel, was die Ports unterstützen. Und da muss man natürlich auch sehen, dass jetzt die Ports unterschiedlich jung sind. Der Windows-Port sei sehr ausgereift. Da existieren eigentlich keine Kinderkrankheiten mehr, weil es einfach schon so lange existiert und so lange gefixt wird und von vielen Leuten getestet und debugged wurde. Wohingegen der Mac OS-Export eben noch relativ jung ist und von daher eben auch noch einige Sachen verbessert werden können.
Jetzt haben wir es ja schon eingangs erwähnt. Ihr habt euch jetzt hier in größerer Runde, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute sind hier, 20, 30?
Wir sind um die 30.
Hier in Berlin getroffen, GTK plus Hackfest, also mal ein Developer-Meeting quasi zusammengerufen. Wer hat sich jetzt hier alles so eingefunden für diese Woche?
Man kann eigentlich mal sagen, quer durch die Community. Da muss ich noch mal kurz auf die Frage zurückkommen, wer verwendet alles GTK, wenn man es nicht direkt beantwortet. Aber es gibt natürlich diese riesige Gnome-Community, die inzwischen riesig ist. Gnome gibt es jetzt auch schon seit über zehn Jahren. Die benutzt natürlich alle GTK. Und dann gibt es auch noch Communities daneben, wie zum Beispiel die Memo-Plattform, die Nokia jetzt gestartet hat auf diesen kleinen Devices. Die haben auch komplett selber GTK verwendet.
Also auch diesen, wie heißt er?
N77, N800, N810.
Also diese reinen Teile ohne Telefon, die eigentlich nur ein Internet-Tablet sind.
Genau, Internet-Tablet ist eigentlich wohl das, wie es vermarktet wird. Und die haben, die benutzen auch GTK für den gesamten Desktop und haben viele Anpassungen vorgenommen, um themen zu können, also praktisch, um ihre eigene, sagen wir mal, ihren eigenen Look-Stempel darauf zu drücken. Das ist eine Community, die natürlich inzwischen auch schon relativ groß hier gewachsen ist, Gnome. Und da gibt es noch ein paar, es gibt noch ein paar einzelne vereinzelte GTK-Applikationen, die jetzt nicht in Gnome eingegliedert sind, die aber auf GTK aufsetzen. Und so ein guter Querschnitt davon ist eigentlich inzwischen hier aufgetaucht. Im Allgemeinen haben wir für dieses Hackfest insbesondere uns Leute herausgesucht, wo wir wissen, die sind aktive Langzeit-Kontributoren oder sind gerade dabei, das zu werden. Und das hat dazu geführt, dass wir Leute von Red Hat hier haben, von Novel, von Nokia, von Imendio natürlich, weil wir sehr viel mit GTK machen, von Canonical.
Und wie kam das jetzt ausgerechnet in Berlin und nicht in den USA?
Wir haben auf die Weltkarte geguckt und festgestellt, die meisten sitzen ja in Europa.
Openismus natürlich, die haben das nämlich tatsächlich hier in Berlin organisiert. Openismus, eine Firma, die sitzen unten in München und einer der Hauptmitarbeiter hat das hier tatsächlich für uns auch in Berlin organisiert. Eine der Kontributoren hat sich angeboten, das in Berlin hier stattfinden zu lassen, die Location zu organisieren, die notwendigen Ressourcen, die Buchung und so weiter zu übernehmen. Ja, genau. Wobei Community tatsächlich, also das haben wir jetzt eben schon gehört, weil wir mehrere Firmennamen aufgelistet haben, es gibt tatsächlich viele Firmen, die auch ein kommerzielles Interesse an GTK haben, weil sie es einfach in ihren Produkten einsetzen. Und von daher heißt Community-Sponsoring hier tatsächlich auch Firmen-Sponsoring.
Ja klar, also nicht zu ihrem Nachteil, aber es wird halt explizit mal Geld in die Community reingereicht, damit sie sich eben besser organisieren kann, weil ansonsten treibt sie ja eigentlich viel Lust und Laune.
Wir haben natürlich auch noch Support von der Gnome Foundation selber. Das muss man auch noch sagen. Also das Gnome-Projekt als Community-Projekt hat es tatsächlich auch noch unterstützt. Das liegt ein bisschen daran, wie es eigentlich zu diesem Hack festgekommen ist.
Ja, wie denn? Ist das das erste Mal, dass ihr euch so trefft?
Dass wir uns wirklich mit dem Fokus GTK auf einer kleinen Mini-Konferenz treffen, ist genau das erste Mal. Und das liegt daran, dass nach der 2.0er, wie ja schon beschrieben hat, die hat tatsächlich mehrere Jahre in Anspruch genommen, war so dieses riesen Feature-Ding, das jeder haben wollte und wo alles rein musste, was dann perfekt sein sollte. Seit der 2.0er haben wir eigentlich die ABI, das Application Binary Interface, haben wir beibehalten. Und keine wirklich inkubativen Änderungen gemacht, damit Applikationen darauf aufsetzen konnten und sich auf dieses Interface verlassen. Und wir haben in dem Sinne eigentlich nur noch Erweiterungen dazugebastelt und muss sagen, dass das nach vielen Jahren jetzt langsam so eine Art Belastung wird. Man kann die nicht ewig aufrechterhalten. Man muss einfach eine Code-Basis auch immer mal wieder umwandeln, refactoren, um die am Leben zu erhalten, um sie vernünftig weiter warten zu können. Von der Main-Tender-Seite her haben wir gemerkt, dass wir ein bisschen festgefahren sind mit dieser Policy einerseits und mit den Anforderungen, die z.B. auch durch das iPhone oder das neue Betriebssystem, das Apple ausgebracht hat, zeigen Dinge, die man mit dem Toolkit machen kann, die man unter Umständen in den GTK oder so zurückfließen lassen will. Da stellt sich die Frage, wie macht man das entwicklungstechnisch? Wie bekommt man das auf die Code-Basis drauf? Muss man dafür nicht größere Teile umwandeln?
Was sind das für Sachen, die euch da besonders reizen?
Animationen sind das.
So was wie Core-Animation bei Leopard.
Das ist tatsächlich der technische Name von einer Funktionalität. Aber wenn man sich die User-Interface-Experience anguckt, also die Erfahrung, die der User selber macht, das ist sehr interessant.
Der Welt schreit nach Coverflow. Wirklich? Media Player gibt es auf jeder Plattform.
Ob es wirklich nötig ist, ist bei einigen Sachen noch die Frage. Aber es gibt auch viele Dinge, die man sich ansieht auf dieser Plattform, die einfach schöner wirken, als wenn man zu diesem alten statischen Konzept verbleibt, wo einfach Widgets einfach nur angezeigt werden, sind da, sind weg. Das ist bei Mercure alles flüssig animiert. Man hat wirklich den Eindruck, dass gäbe so etwas wie physikalische Übergänge. Oder es fühlt sich an, wenn man zum Beispiel den Mauspointer über den Nettiste bewegt und die läuft dann noch einen Augenblick nach, macht so eine Art Beschleunigungsbewegung. Das sind wirklich Dinge, die wirken im ersten Blick ein bisschen subtil. Aber in der Masse verwitten sie dem User einfach ein besseres Gefühl beim Umgang mit dem Computer. Und da steckt im Endeffekt natürlich eine ganze Menge Technik dahinter. Und das muss man erstmal in so ein Toolkit reinfließen lassen können, dass eventuell auch schon eine gut etablierte Code-Base ist, wie bei GTK der Fall ist. Und da haben wir als Maintenor einfach so gemerkt, dass es relativ schwierig ist, inzwischen auch Teile aufzuräumen. Und dass es gab, bis vor zwei Jahren eigentlich so eine Zusammenfassung der verschiedenen Maintenance-Probleme um GTK herum, dass wir auch teilweise Probleme haben, den ganzen Bugreports und Patches, die es aus der Community gab, hinterherzukommen, weil das Core-Team relativ klein ist um GTK herum. Da ist auch ein paar Änderungen gegeben und dann waren einfach nicht so viele Ressourcen da, wie wir es gerne gehabt hätten. Und da haben sich natürlich verschiedene Firmen, die ein Interesse daran haben und auch die Gnome Foundation, Gedanken gemacht und das ist im Endeffekt tatsächlich auf dieses Heckfest hier hinaus gelaufen. Wir unterstützen jetzt eine Zusammenkunft von Core-Team-Mitgliedern und ein bisschen weiter, damit die sich zusammensetzen können, überlegen, wo führen wir das hin, wie machen wir das und im Prinzip wie realisieren wir eine skalierbare Zukunft so fünf, zehn Jahre für die Toolkit?
Vielleicht sollte man nochmal kurz hier den Eindruck, ich mal den Eindruck vermitteln, den ich hier habe. Also das ist jetzt hier nicht so eine Konferenzatmosphäre, sondern ihr habt euch hier irgendwie ein paar Apartments gemietet mitten in Berlin. Das ist alles total cozy. Also man hat das Gefühl, man ist hier irgendwie bei irgendjemandem zu Hause. Ihr macht halt hier so abwechselnd wahrscheinlich kleine Talks und Besprechungsrunden und dann wird einfach mal wieder locker vor sich hingehakt. Was sind dann so die Themen, die ihr dann so ausrollt, um den Zukunftsaufgaben da entgegenzukommen?
Das Hauptthema, damit haben wir jetzt auch wirklich diese Konferenz hier, diese Mini-Konferenz begonnen, ist halt Visionen um GTK herum. Wo gibt es eine Zukunft und wenn es eine Zukunft gibt, wie sieht die aus? Das ist eigentlich so die große Frage, die im Raum stand. Und da hat sich Emendio speziell hingesetzt vor der Konferenz, sich wirklich überlegt, was ist eine mögliche Zukunftsvision. Wie sehen Wege aus, um die zu implementieren? Und die haben wir eigentlich direkt am Konferenzbeginn hier vorgestellt. Die entschließen auf jeden Fall ein, dass wir demnächst mal die ARBI brechen, damit wir wirklich aufräumen können, kräftig. Und das ist natürlich ein Bruch mit der bisherigen, oder der jetzt seit mehreren Jahren etablierten Development-Philosophie. Und deshalb stellt auch die Frage, kann man das durchsetzen? Kann man das der Community zumuten und bekommt das die notwendige Akzeptanz?
Keine Verbesserung ohne Änderung.
Richtig, genau. Und wenn man sich die Literatur anguckt im Feld, dann ist es überhaupt nicht ungewöhnlich, Software umzuschreiben, zu refactoren, zu wandeln, das ist einfach nötig, damit man es langfristig warten kann. Damit man es langfristig fördern und neue Visionen implementieren kann.
Vorhin hattet ihr im Vorgespräch kurz angedeutet, dass wie in so vielen anderen Projekten auch WebKit Einzug halten soll. Ist das schon spruchreif, oder?
Es gibt dieses WebKit-Projekt und das...
Also WebKit muss man kurz erwähnen, die HTML-Rendering Engine, die ursprünglich mal von KDE kam, als KHTML dann von Apple aufgegriffen wurde und jetzt breiteste Verwendung findet eigentlich fast überall. Alle außer Microsoft machen das jetzt. Bei euch soll das auch Einzug halten.
Ja, bei WebKit stellt sich erst mal die Frage, dass das mit dem Toolkit GTK gut integriert. Und da gibt es jetzt halt mehrere Leute, die da dran arbeiten.
Ja, da ist im letzten Sommer ein Projekt im Rahmen vom Google Summer of Code gewesen, das dafür gesorgt hat, dass eine grobe Integration von WebKit in GTK machbar ist. Sprich, die Schriftverwaltung und alles, was irgendwie Plattform- oder Toolkit-spezifisch an Darstellungselementen ist, entsprechend in WebKit zu implementieren. Und dann letzten Endes auch die Widgets, die Elemente zu liefern, die dann in die Anwendung eingebaut werden und dann in WebKit entsprechend rein aufrufen, um diese Rendering-Funktionalität zu bieten. Das hat sich in den letzten neun Monaten ziemlich weit entwickelt. Wir sind jetzt mit dem WebKit-Projekt an der Stelle, dass wir sagen, das ist in einem halben Jahr fertig für Gnome, dass das in Gnome benutzt werden kann. Und einige Leute in Gnome sind da auch sehr heiß drauf, das dann entsprechend zu verwenden.
Das heißt, jetzt sind wir auch an einem interessanten Punkt angelangt. Jetzt haben wir ja die ganze Zeit über GTK gesprochen. Und sozusagen das Subsystem, das sich jetzt über lange Zeit entwickelt hat. Eingangs haben wir ja schon erwähnt, es soll hier auch um Gnome gehen. Vielleicht können wir mal kurz erwähnen, was Gnome eigentlich ist. Also wo fängt das an?
Gnome sind erstmal zwei Dinge. Gnome ist eine Entwicklungsplattform, die darauf ausgelegt ist, eine Basis zu bieten, um Anwendungsentwicklern zu ermöglichen, mit geringem Aufwand ihre Anwendung zu entwickeln. Also im letzten Ende über GTK hinaus weitergehende Interoperabilität mit anderen Anwendungen zu bieten. Und das Ganze nachher zu einem relativ runden Paket für den Anwendungsentwickler gestalten zu lassen. Und auf der anderen Seite natürlich die Desktop-Umgebung, die dann auf dieser Technik aufsetzt und entsprechend Dateimanager, E-Mail-Programm und diverse andere Basisfunktionalität bietet.
Und was bedeutet das? Ist das jetzt vergleichbar? Was gehört dazu? Es gibt diesen Desktop, das ist sozusagen, dass ich verwalte meine Dateien, ich verwalte den Computer im weiteren Sinne.
Genau, da sind Dinge bei wie der Dateimanager, das E-Mail-Programm, der Web-Browser, diverse Werkzeuge wie der Taschenrechner. Genau, die Leisten, über die dann entsprechend Anwendungen gestartet werden, in denen Fenster aufgelistet werden, wo aber auch Statussymbole oder eine Uhrzeit dargestellt werden kann. Diverse kleine Uplets, die in diese Leisten hinein gepackt werden können, um diese mit Funktionalität zu erweitern.
Systemeinstellungen, wir hatten auch schon das Kontrollcenter erwähnt.
Genau, Desktop-weite Einstellungen, mittlerweile aber auch System-weite Einstellungen. Wir liefern Gnome System Tools, das ist eine grafische Oberfläche, für Systemeinstellungen, die dann abhängig von den jeweiligen Distributoren unterschiedlich implementiert wird in einem separaten Backend, sodass man eine und dieselbe Oberfläche auf verschiedenen Plattformen verwenden kann. Das ist letzten Endes Gnome.
Und inwieweit greift Gnome denn konkret in die Anwendungsentwicklung rein? Ich meine, wenn ich so höre so Desktop, das klingt erstmal nach all dem, was sozusagen um das Programm drum herum ist. Aber wenn ich jetzt eine Anwendung entwickle mit GTK, gibt es dann auch etwas, was ich von Gnome nehme, was Teil meiner Anwendung wird?
Das gab früher extrem viel. Mittlerweile ist aber vieles von solchen Dingen, also es gab extra eine Lipgnome, die dann Gnome-spezifische Funktionalitäten gemanagt hat, eine Lipgnome-UI, die dann Gnome-spezifische, benutzer-sichtbare Elemente, wie zum Beispiel den About-Dialog oder so geboten hat. Das Gip Lipglay, eine Bibliothek, die dafür sorgt, dass man Benutzer-Interfaces nicht mehr in Code gießen muss, sondern sie dynamisch in einer XML-Datei speichern kann, diese XML-Datei zum Start der Anwendung laden kann und dass letzten Endes ein User-Interface-Designer diese XML-Datei verändern kann nach gewissen Regeln, ohne dass der Programmierer davon in irgendeiner Art und Weise betroffen ist, dass dieses Programm jetzt endlich mal aufgehübscht wird. Aber das sind alles Dinge, die in den vergangenen sechs Jahren in deutlich aufgeräumter Art und Weise Einzug auch in GTK gefunden haben, wo wir als Gnome 2.0 im Moment einiges an Funktionalität doppelt bieten.
Was heißt die aktuelle Version jetzt?
Die aktuelle Gnome-Version ist Gnome 2.22. Die ist gestern rausgekommen, vorgestern? Vorgestern rausgekommen, Mittwoch. Da warten wir natürlich, weil wir uns bei Gnome an den, was die erste Ziffer in der Versionsnummer angeht, nach GTK richten, darauf, dass dann bei GTK 3 dann endlich der große Aufräumsschritt erfolgt, dass auch wir bei Gnome sagen können, hey Leute, wenn ihr eure Anwendung bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt aufgeräumt habt, die neue Funktionalität nutzt, die alte nicht mehr, dann habt ihr überhaupt nichts zu befürchten, und dann werden wir endlich alles los, was irgendwie zurzeit doppelt in unserer Code-Basis existiert.
Also ich habe jetzt den Eindruck, vielleicht verstehe ich das auch falsch, aber jetzt bei Mac und auch bei KDE herrscht ja so das Prinzip vor, man nimmt Frameworks und die greifen sehr umfangreich in die Anwendungsentwicklung mit ein. Also wenn ich da anfange zu programmieren, dann bin ich eigentlich sozusagen, bevor ich überhaupt eine Zeile Code geschrieben habe, komplett ummantelt von diesen System-Frameworks, die irgendwie alles definieren. Die Optik, irgendwie wie die Fenster aussehen, diverse Inhalte, auch dieser Fenster bis hin zum Webbrowser, diese Webkit-Beispiel. Das kommt sozusagen alles vom OS und das Programm ist einfach enorm verzahnt mit diesem Subsystem. Jetzt habe ich so den Eindruck, dass das bei Gnome nicht so stark der Fall ist, auch offensichtlich nicht das Ziel ist.
Wir haben sehr viel Wert darauf gelegt, die einzelnen Komponenten, die wir haben, als separate Module bereitzustellen, um die Einstiegsbarriere für einen Anwendungsentwickler, der letzten Endes über den reinen GTK-Rahmen hinaus schaut, möglichst gering zu halten. Dass man zum Beispiel nicht gezwungen ist, eine 30 MB Gigabit Bibliothek einzubinden, nur um das Benutzerinterface aus einem XML-Datei zu laden. Wenn das eine separate Bibliothek ist, tendieren die Entwickler eher, nach unserer Auffassung, eher dazu, sich bereit zu erklären, wirklich diese Funktionalität zu verwenden, weil sie selbst auf einer relativ guten Granularität entscheiden können, wie viel über GTK hinaus sie in ihre Anwendung einbinden möchten und wollen.
Das heißt, alles folgt eigentlich noch mehr dem Gedanken von Bibliotheken. Wenn ich eine bestimmte Funktionalität haben will, dann bediene ich mich an einer bestimmten Bibliothek, und wenn ich sie irgendwie nicht brauche, dann lasse ich sie einfach komplett raus. Anders als jetzt bei KDE oder auf Mac, wo man sagt, ich bin sowieso Teil des Gesamtframeworks, und alles ist sowieso da.
Weil viele Anwendungsentwickler für sich auch gar nicht dieses Selbstverständnis haben, dass sie sagen, ich bin Teil des Gesamtsystems und des Gesamtsystems ohnehin da. Auch gerade im Zusammenhang mit dieser Geschichte zur Plattform-Unabhängigkeit, dass man die Wahl hat, welche Komponenten man sich aus dem Gnome-Umfeld holen möchte, weil die teilweise nicht im ähnlichen Umfang plattformübergreifend funktionieren, wie GTK selbst, und einige andere sogar unterschiedliche Lösungen schon auf diesen Plattformen vorfinden. Wir haben bei Gnome zum Beispiel einen Hilfe-Betrachter, der SGML-Dateien als HTML darstellt. Unter OS X wird Preview benutzt, eine PDF-Betrachter als Hilfemechanismus. Wenn man seine Anwendung vernünftig unter OS X integrieren möchte, möchte man natürlich dann auch wie jede andere OS X-Anwendung Preview für Hilfe verwenden. Und das ist bei dieser relativ feinen Granularität sehr überschaubar für den Anwendungsentwickler zu sehen, wo verlasse ich sichere Pfade und wo muss ich dann irgendwie selbstwomöglich eingreifen, um mehr Plattform-Unabhängigkeit in der Anwendung zu realisieren.
Jetzt haben wir ja schon mehr verfallen gelassen. Das ist ja auch eigentlich eine allgemeine Erkenntnis. Es gibt halt Gnome und GTK als das eine. Die eine Welt, die G-Welt, es gibt KDE. Unter Linux hat das natürlich bei vielen Anwendern immer auch immer so dieses Bedürfnis-Effekt, so Gott, warum brauchen wir denn zwei unterschiedliche Sachen? Warum kann denn das nicht irgendwie einheitlich sein? Ich denke, dass die G-Welten, die K-Welten immer noch in vollkommen unterschiedlichen Richtungen marschieren und von daher wahrscheinlich auch unterschiedliche Märkte auf lange Zeit adressieren. KDE sehr schwerpunktmäßig auch so auf die Rich Applications hin. GTK ist in meinen Augen korreiert, wenn ihr den Eindruck nicht teilt, lässt sich vor allem einen sehr großen Spielraum, worauf sich Anwendungen konzentrieren und auf welchen Betriebssystemen und Plattformen diese dann laufen, weil es eben nicht so viele Anforderungen stellt. Trotzdem gibt es ja so einen Versuch, die beiden Plattformen sich zumindest annähern zu lassen, unter dem Namen fridesktop.org glaube ich. Was steckt denn dahinter?
Da steckt letzten Endes hinter, dass auch wenn KDE und Gnome unterschiedliche Philosophien verfolgen, nicht jeder 100% KDE-Nutzer oder 100% Gnome-Nutzer ist. Und es Leute gibt, die K3B unter Gnome benutzen möchten oder Evolution unter KDE. Und dass in diesen Situationen natürlich eine gewisse Interoperabilität erforderlich ist. Und wir haben uns überlegt, wir setzen uns zusammen. Gnome, KDE, ROKS, das ist eine andere kleine Desktop-Umgebung. Aber auch nicht Desktop-Umgebungsprojekte, wie zum Beispiel Mozilla oder OpenOffice. Und wir überlegen uns, was muss man eigentlich machen, um sich auf einem freien Desktop sauber zu integrieren. Genau deshalb diese Bezeichnung freedesktop.org.
Also frei jetzt mal nicht im Sinne von freier Software, sondern frei...
Ja, letzten Endes schon. Freier Desktop im Sinne von Desktop basierend auf freier Software. Aber dass man letzten Endes Schnittstellen schafft, die dafür zu sorgen, dass man dann aus einem Conqueror eine Datei in Evolution per Drag-and-Drop reinziehen kann. Oder eben aus einem Nautilus in K3b, wo man dann entsprechend sogar Toolkit- und Frameworkgrenzen überschreitet. Wo man sich schlicht und ergreifend hinsetzen muss und mal ausformulieren muss, wie dann diese Interoperabilitätsschnittstelle aussehen muss. Damit man dann solche Leistungen entsprechend vollbringen kann.
Was ist das für ein Gremium, oder ist das so ein Webforum, oder eine Mailingliste, wo die Köpfe sich heiß geredet werden?
Es ist eine Webplattform, bei der letzten Endes jeder willkommen ist, der sagt, ich habe folgendes Problem XY, ich habe einen vernünftigen Ansatz.
Es gehört noch ein bisschen aus der Infrastrukturecke heraus, weil um ein Desktop-Plattform wie Gnome oder KDE zu entwickeln, gibt es einige Dinge, die man grundlegend schaffen muss, wie zum Beispiel die Kommunikations-Zwischenprogramm. Diese Infrastruktur-Komponenten zu schaffen, da ist ganz oft aufgefallen, dass sie sinnvoll über ein einzelnes Desktop-Projekt hinaus sind. Die sind nur Anfang für ein paar Jahre in Gnome und KDE geradezu konkurrierend aufgezogen worden, bis dann irgendwann diese Idee aufkam, dass das ineffizient und schwer für weitere Applikationen zu unterstützen, weil es immer diese zwei konkurrierenden Systeme gibt, die man verwenden muss. Dann kam diese Idee nach dem Free Desktop auf, dass man sich in einigen Infrastruktur-Komponenten einfach zusammensetzt, um das gemeinsam zu spezifizieren und deshalb projektunabhängig weiterzuentwickeln. Das ging los mit der Spezifikation für Extended Window-Manager-Hints und später D-Bus. Da versuchte der Free Desktop einfach eine Art Umwelt zu schaffen, was Web-Space betrifft, Mailing-Listen, aber auch Projekt-Hosting und so, wo sich Leute eben Desktop-Projekte unspezifisch ausdrücken können, wo diese Projekte unterstützt werden.
Das D-Bus, was du erwähnt hast, was ist das für ein Subsystem? Was spielt das für eine Rolle?
Da geht es eigentlich darum, dass Programme untereinander Nachrichten austauschen können. Da hatten Gnome und KDE auch für lange Zeit immer unterschiedliche Ansätze verfolgt, wie du vorhin schon Kaube erwähnt hattest. KDE hat lange auf Kaube gesetzt mit Maiko und es hat sehr viel länger bei Gnome gedauert, um zu sehen, dass das nicht funktioniert. Gnome hat versucht, sein eigenes Kaube aufzuziehen mit Orbit und das hat dann auch nicht so schön funktioniert und Bonobo drauf. Also da sind auch eine ganze Menge Technologien entwickelt worden und da wieder den Fluss runter gespült worden, der im Endeffekt darauf hinaus lief, dass Programme einfach nur miteinander kommunizieren können. Und Dibus hat wirklich versucht, diese Grundfunktionalität möglichst simpel zur Verfügung zu stellen und das tatsächlich dann auch von Anfang an mit dem Anspruch verfolgt, dass es bei beiden Desktop-Projekten akzeptiert wird.
Das klappt doch.
Ja, das funktioniert ziemlich gut. Also es gibt einige Projekte, da kann ich zum Beispiel HalfBus erwähnen, das sich darum kümmert, dass OpenType-Pinting-Informationen zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Und dieses HalfBus ist gemeinsame Grundlage für das Front-Rendering in Pango auf der einen Seite im GTK-Gnome-Stack und genauso für QT auf der anderen Seite im KDE-QT-Stack. Schriften sind natürlich auch so etwas, was man nicht alles doppelt machen möchte. Genau, die möchte man einmal und richtig haben und da hat man überhaupt kein Interesse an der Front-Rendering.
Hilft sowas dann auch bei der Integration von WebKit?
Sowas hilft bei WebKit selbst jetzt nicht direkt, aber letzten Endes ist das halt schon sehr praktisch, sowas zu sehen. WebKit selber hilft eher bei Halfbuzz mit, weil es als Open-Source-Projekt mit all den Implementationen, ja auch die Mac OS X-Implementation ist ja freie Software, Quelltext liefert, den wir uns anschauen können, der uns zeigt, wie Dinge unter OS X gemacht werden. Und die letzten Endes auch dafür sorgen, dass wir zum Beispiel unsere Plattform besser auf Windows und OS X laufen lassen können, weil wir in WebKit direkt sehen können, wie das schon jetzt unter Windows und OS X gehandelt wird.
Ja, ich denke, wir haben jetzt das Thema ganz gut durchgeackert. Insofern mache ich mal Schluss. Wir werden jetzt hier auch langsam herauskomplimentiert mit diesem Podcast. Gemeinsam ist auch das GTK Hackfest so langsam zum Ende gekommen, oder heute ist der letzte Tag.
Wir hatten heute Morgen noch mal einen Web-Up und ich habe ja noch mit vielen Leuten zwischendurch verschiedene Diskussionen gehabt, um verschiedene neue Technologien in den GTK zu integrieren und habe nicht überall jemandem über die Schulter gucken können, was denn da tatsächlich so gehackt wurde. Von daher war bei diesem Web-Up eigentlich ganz nett zu sehen, dass sich tatsächlich viele kleine Gruppen gebildet haben, die auch teilweise Themen besprochen haben, die jetzt nicht direkt auf dem Schedule standen oder nur beiläufig erwähnt worden sind, die aber schon länger so in der Luft hingen, wo es wirklich gut war, dass die Leute zusammengefunden haben. Und es haben sich tatsächlich auch kleine Gruppen gebildet, die an Patches gearbeitet haben, teilweise auch integrieren konnten in verschiedene Projekte. Es wurde sogar dem Namen Hackfest mehr gerecht, als ich erwartet hatte.
Das heißt, das Modell lässt sich auch weiterempfehlen für andere Gruppen.
Das scheint der Fall zu sein.
Einfach mal so ein paar Appartements anmieten und sich zusammenfinden.
Wir haben diese Empfehlung an die Gnome Foundation weitergegeben, dass das eventuell auch ein Format ist, das über GTK hinaus für andere Teile von Gnome sinnvoll anzuwenden sein kann. Es ist eigentlich sehr produktiv gewesen. Es hat von vielen Leuten die Erwartung tatsächlich übertroffen.
Ja, was mir gleich so aufgefallen ist, ist, dass hier so viele Wohnungen gemeinsam in einem Haus gemietet wurden. Man ist ja irgendwie unter sich, man schläft hier vor Ort, man hat keine weiten Wege. Wir machen ja hier gerade den BVG-Streik durch. Keine Straßenbahn, kein Bus fährt in dieser Stadt. Das hat euch, glaube ich, alles nicht weiter tangiert. Ja, insofern eine Empfehlung auch an andere Gruppen, die sich mal gegenseitig kennenlernen wollen. Ich denke, die meisten kannten sich hier auch nicht unbedingt so ohne Weiteres.
Nicht persönlich, nein.
Oder nur sporadisch von Konferenzen.
Von wo kamen jetzt irgendwie die Leute von Ländern her?
Das erstreckt sich von Kanada bis Australien, Brasilien bis Finnland.
Sogar Finnland. Also durch das Sponsoren sind dann Flüge auch entsprechend bezahlt worden, sodass die Leute dann einfach mal diese Strecke treten konnten. Ja, das ist doch eigentlich eine super Sache. Da kann man sich auch nur die Firmen, die vielleicht auch bei Cartradio Express zuhören, ermuntern, die Open-Source-Community, wo sie da die Gelegenheit sehen, auch durch solche Sachen zu unterstützen. Das kam auch schon bei dem Gespräch mit Sven zum Thema Gimp mit raus, dass also eigentlich dieses Konferenzen ist eigentlich das, wo man wirklich am wertvollsten wirklich solche Programmierprojekte auch an, nach vorne bringen kann. Dass die Community sich wirklich mal konkret trifft, weil alle anderen Sachen, die eigentlich immer so diesen Ruch von, ach Gott ist das teuer, was weiß ich, so wie Webserver und so weiter, das ist ja etwas, was in dieser Technik-Community sich immer irgendwie von alleine löst. Also so Treffik und so weiter sind immer so alles gar keine wirklichen Themen, was für andere Leute Probleme sind. Aber das Real-Life-Meeting, das ist die eigentliche Herausforderung. Ja, ich sage erstmal Dankeschön, Tim.
Vielen Dank für die Gelegenheit.
Sven, dass ihr hier eure letzte Stunde noch dem Chaos Radio Express geopfert habt. Ja, und ich kann nur hoffen, dass euch auch das hier weitere Einblicke geliefert hat in Gnome und GTK. Und Feedback dazu ist immer gerne gesehen. Seht ihr bei uns auf dem Blog, blog.chaosradio.ccc.de oder schreibt uns eine E-Mail. chaosradio.ccc.de Feedback ist immer gerne gesehen. Und dann wünsche ich euch noch einen schönen Tag und bis bald bei Chaos Radio Express.